- Hey guys, first of all
thank you for clicking.
You're about to watch a new video,
or another video, on YouTube
and before you do, 212-931-5731.
What I'm doing in my text
community is bonkers,
it's instant, it's access, it's exclusive.
And now enjoy this YouTube video.
(air whooshing)
(clicking)
I actually don't give a fuck about this.
- [Man] Okay.
- If you're really, really, like really,
I wish, if you were here,
no success, like financially
but happy as fuck?
- Right.
- I would fucking hug you
and be like bro you fucking won life.
(cheering)
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
(rewinding)
♪ We can do it if you say so ♪
♪ Keep it quiet I'ma lay low ♪
♪ Show me love but it's fake though yeah ♪
♪ Cause she's a devil with a halo ♪
Again, maybe my face kind of like,
maybe a professor hat,
whatever you wanna do.
This is the place and
the category of content
that most people get caught.
They become super mundane and putting out
the same kinds of pictures,
because they're feeding the algorithm,
and putting out photos
that they know will work,
thus eventually making all
their photos look the same.
I would rather have
underperforming photos,
and mix it up, because
it gives me the potential
to actually find the
next pillar of pictures
that expand my audience.
Stop fearing the algorithm.
Dustin got that whole thing,
I think you should cut it.
I want it verbatim.
I'm gonna make it.
- Yeah.
- [Male] That'd be dope.
- I know you figure it.
- Yeah.
- I'm actually a little bit tricky.
I've got my little pseudo
Bart Simpson kind of like,
well not, I mean this was the cartoon
that I consistently drew.
This is basically what I did in school
from 7th to 11th grade.
I drew this guy literally in every class.
In every class, this dude--
- [Male] Oh, that's pretty good.
- Thanks bro.
- [Male] I'm impressed G.
- [Male] That's good.
- Thanks bro.
(man giggles)
(group laughs)
- Post it!
(man Laughs)
- He's gonna make--
- But by the way, this
is very meta, right?
The fact that right now,
literally we're in this meeting trying
to teach people that they're
overthinking, you know.
- Content?
- Content and like,
(phone Dings)
I've got a tweet up already.
(group Laughs)
Gonna reply to that tweet.
(phone Dings)
(man with beard laughs)
I'm going into my Instagram story.
Boom.
Now kindness is king.
Boom, done.
Then I'm going to Snap.
Boom.
Now I'm doing this.
Yo, what's good?
If you're confused, kindness is king!
(phone dings)
Now I have a Snap.
Boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom.
Good, now I'm going on Instagram Live.
I mean, this is like--
- [Drock] Gary, can you
give me a five for a minute.
Yeah, move away from your drawing.
Thanks.
- Boom.
Now I'm on live.
Yo Instagram.
I just drew this.
It's my guy from 7th to 11th grade
that I used to draw all the time.
Kindness is king.
I'm going live.
I'm working on a deck
for you guys right now.
It's super meta, Dustin's making a vlog.
(group laughs)
This is how it's done!
Fucking make!
Stop thinking, start making!
(phone dings)
Boom, live.
- Avital and I are in
trouble and she's drawing.
(group laughs)
- Your careers are over.
(music drowns out speaker)
- Do you put a comma after good?
I mean, I know I'm the worst with grammar.
If you're good comma people?
- Yeah.
- Because I was like, "If you're
good people," is that good?
(group laughs)
(laughing drowns out speaker)
Cool, no worries.
By the way, can we,
(group laughs)
this needs to go on Social.
(laughs)
This is, I mean, I'm more likely,
I am more likely to find
a $400,000 rare jewel
at a Trash Talk episode,
than what just happened here
with a proper understanding of grammar.
(laughs)
Oh my god!
Mrs. Horvath, we did it!
(mellow music)
- [MAle] Why I'm here is, I don't know how
to monetize what I'm doing.
I've hit a lot of bumps in the road
where I don't know where to go from here.
I'm selling on Ebay.
- What would you like to happen?
Be more successful, in theory?
- Yeah.
- And what about happiness?
Where are you on the,
to me, it's really,
when I hear that question,
here's all I think about, right?
(phone rings)
Hey guys, sorry to interrupt your video.
I'm just giving you
this call from my number
to let you know that you have to join
my text community.
212-931-5731.
Hit me up with a text.
Happiness, right?
And financial success, right?
- [Male] Right.
- And as you know,
I don't think people are
talking about that enough.
Right, right?
- Which I've seen.
- So, I want you here and I think people
are focused too much here,
which makes them unhappy,
and that's why they burn out.
So for me, when you ask that question,
I'm trying to figure this out.
- [Male] Do you get the vibe I'm here?
- No.
- Okay.
- No, but anybody who
sells something is actually
in a real business.
- Right.
- So at least you have the chance,
plus your fucking basement looked good.
So, no I don't get the
vibe that you're here.
You may or may not be.
Here's actually, that was a really
interesting insight by you.
I actually don't give a fuck about this.
- [Male] Okay.
- If you really, really, like really,
I wish, if you were here,
no success, like financially,
but happy as fuck?
- Right.
- I'd be sup, I would fucking hug you
and be like, "Bro, you fucking won life."
- [Male] Right.
- This is obviously what a lot
of people are trying to figure out.
Listen, I'm here.
You know?
- Can I give you a quick-
- Thing on this?
- Yes.
- Okay, because the one
place I'm most scared
of is here.
- Okay.
- A lot
of people get here and lose.
This is the people I'm going after.
And then obviously-
- They just want and want.
- And obviously this scares
the super shit out of me.
- When that crumbles.
- Well this is the worst spot right?
- Right, right.
- You know?
VaynerMedia is not your typical agency.
We are fueled by an entrepreneurial spirit
and grounded in three G's
of generosity, grind and gratitude.
Next. (laughs)
This is why we always get out of things
that are booked for four,
Drock, were you with me when we had
that four hour booking for something
and we were done in like 20 minutes?
- Yeah man, because I got to go back.
I'm gonna jump a ride.
(Western music drowns out speaker)
- [Gary] All right, what's happening?
I'm a little bit confused.
Are we doing admins or
am I calling this kid?
- You're gonna call him.
- We can.
Whether or not, it's a
three hour meeting in-
- I want you to film it.
- Oh, okay.
- The deaf community filming.
- And you can ask Harwood,
but I think it's good for the archives.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- Well Dustin.
- I'm also doing a time
lapse of just showing,
for the vlog, otherwise
what's the vlog today?
- [Camera Man] We need
the content and the--
- I get it, but I think adding this,
of doing one and a half minutes
of a three hour time lapse,
showing that I have
three four-hour meetings
with Gallery Media Group,
1:37 pm Purell is a good look
for them, good look for all of us.
(upbeat music)
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello.
How are you?
Hello.
- This is Charlie,
my new heir.
- Charlie, nice to meet you.
- It's a pleasure Charlie.
How are you?
- I'm doing well.
- It's a pleasure.
- How's it going?
- Good to see you.
What's up, what's up?
Good to see you guys
- Good to see you Gary.
(upbeat music)